welcome back a big victory at the border
this week with a federal
judge in texas indefinitely blocking
president biden's
100-day freeze on deportations texas
attorney general ken paxton sued the
administration as you know back in
january
calling the executive orders out of
president biden on immigration quote
unconstitutional illegal and bad for
texas and the nation
he joined me on mornings with maria on
friday to
encourage other states and attorneys
generals to fight back
watch it's shocking
the brazenness with which the president
did this in the very first day looking
at federal law and saying
don't worry about federal law passed by
our congress by our elected
representatives
you don't have to worry about it you
don't have to enforce it that is an
edict that is acting more like a king
than it is
a president and so yeah it gives me a
lot of concern that he thinks he can do
this on that issue
why not every other issue which is why
it's so important
that we stand up as he does that if he
does it we need to stand up and fight it
so that he does not continue to do it
joining me right now is former
department of homeland security's acting
secretary chad wolfe he is currently a
visiting fellow at the heritage
foundation
and chad it's good to see you again
thanks very much for being here good
morning to you
well thank you for having me so so many
executive orders to go through with you
an
overturning of yours and president
trump's policies give us the
significance
of this legal win for texas and can can
paxton
in your judgment well it's absolutely
critical and i'm glad the courts ruled
on that what we know from a halt in
deportations
is you are turning on the head the rule
of law and immigration law so if
ice and dhs can't do their job can't
remove individuals that have no legal
right to remain in the u.s
then the whole the whole nature of our
immigration law is up in the air and so
it's the right ruling
unfortunately i would say that dhs has
already decided
to put further restrictions on who ice
law enforcement officers can and cannot
deport
so even though the court ruling is a win
dhs has already given ice instructions
that they can only remove individuals in
three specific classes
those that come across the border those
that are aggravated felons and those
that are
essentially terrorists and which is very
concerning that takes
off the board about 80 to maybe 90
percent of individuals they could
legally remove out of the country and so
again just more concerning actions from
the biden administration
chad the administration also halted the
border wall construction
leaving high volume areas like the rio
grande valley
quite vulnerable we have a shot of the
map here to show people where
most of the people are coming in i know
that your colleagues
have said it's 4 000 people at the
border every day
what is the situation that the the
border patrol agent's face on the ground
walk us through this here yeah
absolutely the border wall system and
i've talked about it
numerous times it's not only that
physical infrastructure which people
usually assume that fence
but it's the it's the lights it's the
cameras it's the roads it's the fiber
optic sensors
that gives border patrol agents the full
picture there on the border and so you
mentioned rgv
there in texas that is ground zero for
illegal entries
into the united states and we had
designated certain high priority
areas for a border wall system and now
we know that the bike administration has
stopped all construction so
it puts a further strain on the men and
women of the border patrol to do their
job and at the end of the day
what it means is you're going to see
more and more individuals coming across
those
areas you mentioned about thirty five
hundred to four thousand
a day is who border patrol is picking up
that doesn't account for what we call
the got aways which is another fifteen
to twenty percent of that numbers that
again they just don't have the resources
to pick up so it's very concerning that
you're going to take a tool off the
table
out of the toolbox for our law
enforcement officials
wow so the 3 500 and 4 thousand is is
that a minimum
then let's take a short break chad i
want to get your reaction to the biden
white house blaming the trump
administration
or the border crisis caused by their
executive orders we'll be right back
with that stay with us with
more chad i want to get your take on
what's happening at the border
we were just talking about all of these
undocumented immigrants president biden
says
they should be getting the covet vaccine
without ice targeting them meanwhile
many high-risk americans who need the
vaccine
don't have the access to the vaccine
he's also planning to make sure
undocumented immigrants have food noting
that his 1.9 trillion dollar coronavirus
relief package
increases funding for nutrition
assistance
for illegals your reaction
it's just more of the incentives that
the bite administration is signaling
to those folks south of the border the
smugglers the traffickers the cartels
now is the time to send those
individuals across the border illegally
because they're going to get a number of
benefits that you outlined
and they're going to be free from any
type of law enforcement action that's
going to remove them so it's
very very concerning as i have said
repeatedly they have brought this crisis
that we see on the southwest border
today
it is of their own making we gave them
as we left
the administration we gave them the
tools we gave them a playbook
that we had kept the situation on the
border under control
and they have decided to take those
tools off the table they have decided to
encourage
and then facilitate that illegal entry
and it's like i said it's it's
concerning it's not only concerning i
think the american people see this
but it's also very concerning for the
dhs law enforcement officers who are on
the front lines
who are now having to deal with
thousands of individuals that have no
medical history have very little
identification you don't know where they
came from and they're having to deal
with these folks in a coveted
environment
and so we're putting their lives at risk
as well and i just uh
again my heart breaks for him and and
everybody's heart is breaking
for them because now they're you know
in these facilities which the binding
administration claims is not the same
situation
that was the case for the trump
administration and during the trump
administration we had all these
headlines that
trump was putting kids in cages i mean
it's absolutely
incredibly you know hypocritical to hear
jen pasaki now the spokesperson for
president biden defend this here she was
this week talking about one of the
biggest stories of the week listen to
this
i just want to ask you about cpac i know
you got some questions about this
yesterday if i could try again
based on our reporting former president
trump is
going to be talking about president
biden's immigration policies he will
point to the uptick in migrants
coming to the u.s how is the
administration planning to respond
well we're not looking to former
president trump or any of his advisors
as a model for how we're approaching
immigration
in fact we're in the circumstance we're
in because uh not only was their
approach
inhumane it was ineffective and so we're
going to forge our own path forward
we'll see what he says but our focus is
certainly not what on president trump is
saying at cpac
your reaction to that chad she says our
own approach but isn't that approach the
same exact buildings
uh where they were kids in cages under
trump but now they're migrant facilities
according to the washington post
well absolutely those comments by jen
pasake are not only absurd they're just
dishonest they're not truthful
i don't believe she knows what she's
talking about look what the situation on
the border today
is again the own making of the biden
administration
they knew the numbers as they were
coming into power as
we were making the transition over to
dhs officials throughout december
and into early january they knew what
the numbers were they knew what the
policies and procedures we had in place
to control those numbers
and what we saw on day one of
inauguration day is they took all of
those tools
off the table and they took them away
from dhs law enforcement personnel
and now we see emails from dhs to ice
to cbp asking them to do more well i
mean that is just
again dishonest to say uh you need to do
more but i'm gonna i'm gonna withhold
a bunch of tools uh that will allow you
to do more um
and so it's just it's as bad as it can
get at the moment we see about 5 800
children coming across that border uh in
january
it's going to be almost double that in
february and we're gonna and they're
forecasting about 1300 or sorry 13 000
uh perhaps in the month of may alone so
you're at crisis levels that you have
never seen before
uh and again it's at their own making
but why why do you have any answer to
why
they're doing this why make so many
people vulnerable
even offering the the illegal immigrants
the the vaccine
before regular americans why
well again it's just a different
approach that they have uh they prefer
not to enforce the law we've seen that
time and time again we talked about it
on the earlier segment
they want to make sure that they
facilitate this entry of illegal
aliens into the country they want them
to stay here in the u.s as they wait for
their immigration proceedings which we
know
the facts will tell us that that they
just don't show up for their immigration
proceedings another
population that's increasing our family
units
between 2014 and 2020 we had over a
million family units individuals making
up families come into the country
almost 90 of them are still here they
are still here
uh either in the shadows or going
through proceedings so what we know and
what the facts tell us is
they don't leave even they even though
they have no legal right to be here and
so i think at the end of the day
one has to assume that's what the biden
administration wants
all right we will leave it there chad
good to see you this morning thanks very
much we'll keep spotlighting these
important issues
for the american people chad wolfe